I would totally marry Kate McKinnon
seriously I love a good point
I guess it makes me stereotype I've seen
Tegan and Sara in concert like five
times I wish I could grow my nails out
oh yeah I only watch Grey's Anatomy for
Callie and Arizona I don't think the
ending of Bend It Like Beckham was
realistic you know I feel like I should
be good at softball
oh my favorite movies Carole I really
identify with Cate Blanchet women adjust
betta kisses you know I don't know I
think Rory and Paris were low-key dating
did you hear they finally came out and
said Wonder Woman is by it's like all
right some good representation and comic
books oh I would totally go to a women's
festival every weekend if I could you
know ladies only I really love tacos
like the food and the job Oh my ex like
that movie my ex girlfriends I should
say I just wish that someone would look
at me the way that Helen Taylor looks at
Serifos our boobs the best
man I love boobs up by the way I love
vagina Wow oh sorry I was just thinking
about how gay I am
there goes like wow